you played versus smurf today he played  french defense  i said that that guy was using an engine  like i didn't play well but he found  every single tactic i wanted to pull off  that was actually hakaru smurf  wait really okay let's keep going  is this wait wait is this is this  charlie you son of a  wait a second is this charlie you took  my elo  i said this guy was using an engine wait  this is charlie charlie's not streaming  is he  you hikaru he snapped  a five-game win streak  i had so much momentum on my side going  into that and i was like this guy's  using an engine he was using something  more powerful than ai he was using the  brain of makaru